Gregory the thirteenth the Julian
calendar and an inconvenient leap year
the connection the reasons our taxi ends
today the fifth of April it means that
in addition to the sugar tax there are a
number of other important changes for
business and all of us coming tomorrow
not least Scotland's own rates of income
tax and changes to personal allowances
else well Patricia mock from Deloitte
strike tax policy in it and Rebecca
Redding tax director a PwC are here to
help talk us through them so good
evening to you both Rebecca let me start
with you what are the main things that
businesses have got to look out for well
in a way is quite good news for business
because we don't have a lot of major
changes coming up this April last year
we had loads of things there were
changes to losses there were changes to
deductions of finance costs but this
year we've got the same tax rate still
at 19 percent the government have talked
about lowing that lowering the rate to
17 but that's not till 2020 so for the
main corporate rules it's very much
business as usual what do you think on
the personal tax run Patricia I guess
the sort of headline grabber is this
extra tax pam we're getting in scotland
well that's right yes the scottish
government can select their own rates
and bans for earnings not for savings
and dividends income and certainly last
year their higher rate threshold was a
bit lower than that in the rest of the
UK but this year we've got some really
quite complicated system so the same
person in allowance then there's a 19%
rate for two thousand pounds there's
then a 20 percent rate for about ten
thousand and a 21 percent rate 41
percent rate 46 percent rate so by and
large all higher than in the UK the
people who will gain from this will be
the lower earners people earning less
than about 26,000 are better off than if
they lived in the UK if you're an
employer and you've got raisins in
Scotland as well as the rest of the UK
that's a real headache for your payroll
isn't it it just goes to show that lots
of good ideas that come out when
politicians think of taxing the way
taxation should work do cause a lot of
complexity and sometimes a lot of people
who aren't
high incomes can be significantly
affected now one of the other things
that's happening someone of the minimum
employer contribution for auto
enrollment pension schemes that's
doubling is that going to be a headache
for employers I think most employers are
prepared for these kind of changes auto
enrollment has been something's been on
the cards for many years we'd like to
think that everybody knew this was
coming and had thought about how it
might be affecting them like a lot of
majors now you do get quite a lot of
lead time which is a good thing of
course Patricia the flip side of this is
that employee contributions are also
rising first so people who are
auto-enrolled
again notice a drop in their take-home
pay next month on they absolutely right
yes and may just may not be expecting
that yeah so employers may well be
prepared but I don't think employees
will be however on the plus side for
most people the lifetime the personal
allowance Rises the personal allowance
Rises yes by not the leaps and bounds
that we've had in the past few years it
just goes up by 3% CPI inflation so up
from 11,500 to 11850 and the higher rate
threshold goes up as well
246 350 the top rate that stays 150 so
nice yes dragged into that top rate of
income tax more yes more and more people
get dragged into that and some other
changes as well meaning that more people
might get dragged in and they would
otherwise I won't change Rebecca that
affects both businesses and
savers is that the cut in the amount of
dividends that you can receive before we
start paying taxes on them comes down
that's a real hit for small business
owners isn't it yes so we've had a 5,000
pounds exemption for dividends for a few
years now it was a year ago roughly last
year's budget when they're trying to
announce he'd be cutting that to two
very unpopular measure from small
business owners but obviously lots of
people do receive small amounts of
dividend income that will still be
covered even if the rates gone down so
if you're running your own business at
least again you've had a year to think
about how this might affect you yeah I
guess if you're a savior Patricia than
5,000 to 2,000
a lot of people won't even get mm all
that I guess well it depends on their
portfolio I guess but I think the main
people affected by this as Becca says
will be the people who've been a set up
to work through a company I'm planning
to pay themselves partly salary and
partly dividend yeah and you know they
may have done that on the basis they
were expecting a 5,000 pound exemption
and now they're getting two thousand and
a good bit of news for pension savers
for the first time in years arise in the
lifetime allowance mm-hmm
yes there's another area of complexity
there is a rise in the lifetime
allowance again by 3% CPI so it's gone
up to a million and thirty thousand
pounds but of course there are lots of
other restrictions in pension savings
allowances so people need to monitor
their overall savings against that but
the annual allowance has not gone up
that's still 40,000 and for higher
earnings of course that's now tapers
down to ten thousand yeah
horrible situation a lot of complexity
for sure all right well I guess that
complexity keeps you both in business
doesn't it Patricia moc Rebecca Redding
thanks both courtesy